there we go okay we are live with
another google hangout I'm excited today
to have one of my fans on with me Deepak
Shukla who is doing an interview series
talking to entrepreneurs and thought
leaders and asked me if I would come on
and answer some of his questions and
some questions that I haven't been asked
before so I'm a little nervous but here
we go over to you Deepak let's start it
thank you and Evans audience really
great to meet you I'm really excited
about this interview and as Ivan right
he said there's a series of questions
that relate to intrapreneurs actually
people that are looking to do
entrepreneurial things within within
companies that they already work in and
also stuff that relates to kind of your
career perhaps before you became an
entrepreneur as well as during so I mean
I'll kick it right off and if you could
describe your career journey in three
sentences to an absolute stranger what
would those three sentences be we're
short on time here you making me think
my career journey in three sentences um
let's see um turn down my dream job
started my own business and sucked
followed my passion and turn my dreams
into a reality Wow okay I'm impressed
looks really pithy and well put together
answer and reflective of what you've
done okay awesome awesome this is going
to be an easier one for you then and
what is the most useful life hack that
you use on a day-to-day basis would ask
to one software in terms of stuff you
use online and then one real world
whatever you choose um interesting
software I run a lot of my stuff through
gmail so maybe gmail it's a kind of
boring answer but uh gmail is my to-do
list right I have everything so
by gmail it's the main way to contact me
when I need to do something those remind
myself I sent myself an email um so
that's probably that's probably my go-to
software tool although it's really super
boring uh maybe one that kind of on top
of that it's beyond I only ask your warm
but I create a dashboard so I have a
home page that i use on my screen every
day when I wake up as all the tools that
I need that I've we've just programmed
it ourselves but easy quick links to all
the different places that I use a
regular basis um personal what's in
light pack I stand up desk has changed
my life sending here stand up desk I've
been doing it for I don't know maybe
three or four years now I got rid of all
the pains in my knees and my lower back
and a little bit healthier so that's
that's my life hack okay all right also
awesome also let's disco okay could you
describe for me what you'd consider to
be the biggest aha moment you've had
when it's come to your own career what
happened the biggest aha moment for me
was realizing that I don't have to come
up with all the answers myself I was I
remember I was struggling i was nineteen
in my first business and just sucking
hard you know making three hundred
dollars a month and and everything I
applied myself at before I had success
with you know in academics if you work
harder you're gonna get higher grades
and piano for practice I get you know I
do better and here I was working on my
business and I felt like I was trying
lots and lots and lots and lots and lots
and I just I wasn't getting anywhere I
was the worst period in my life and the
most damaging to my self-esteem and
self-worth and then my aha moment came
when one you know I told my partner that
I quit again which I ended up going back
but um I realized I wasn't the first guy
to try to do this so I'll selling
software is biotech software and I
realized I'm not the first guy to try to
sell software before and I modeled
Microsoft mcafee and into it and how
they got started I don't care how they
make an extra million but how they got
started and applied that to my business
and I continue to apply it if I'm trying
to learn something new I don't try to
just figure it all out from scratch
myself I realize I'm not the first guy
to try to figure this out okay okay
that's super but I really like that
answer let's let's let's dive into
careers questions as well for some of
the listeners that I have on my side do
you think that the traditional resume
will be dead within 10 years with the
continual growth of LinkedIn obviously
video etc haha I might be the wrong guy
to ask this question because I have a
very different hiring process I don't
even believe in a resume okay I don't
believe it finds a great you're a great
person to Austin and so I'd love to get
her inside so I think the hiring process
for most companies is broken where we're
hiring people based on their ability to
write something on a piece of paper and
a cover letter or resume their ability
to do well in an interview which is
usually the second step for people as
opposed to actually doing the job that
you're hiring them to do you know if I'm
hiring a computer programmer I don't
care how well he interviews when I'm
talking to him face-to-face because I'm
not hiring somebody who's a communicator
necessarily I'm hiring somebody for
their programming skills and so my
hiring process is super different and
strange I which does not involve a CV or
a cover letter or job interviews so in
my world that's already dead but I think
it's going to go more become more and
more dead on going okay superb superb
this is this is this is a this is a
really interesting answer because i
think that there's people that do of
course agree with you out there and
second part of it is it dovetails really
perfectly into the next question that I
want to ask and because of your
non-standard hiring process i'm really
curious as to the answer could you
describe the most memorable job
interview you I ever had or you being
all you've given um ah i was i was
interviewing for a job with merrill
lynch in my last year of university and
i had to decide between doing my
business and taking the
maryland's job which was my dream job at
the time and I member i went to they
flew me to the Wold of her story in New
York and they were interviewing me and I
was in the waiting room and heard people
talk about the new you know president
the Philippines coming in again and and
I went into the job I went into the
interview and I didn't do a lot of
preparation and and they asked me what
what recently happened in the in the
asia-pacific region that's going to have
an impact and so I said well there's a
new president the Philippines just
because I heard it in that room and then
they said well what impact is that going
to have on the region like I had no idea
um and and I don't know I just felt
obviously I like i bombed out of that I
walked out of that room knowing
immediately that there was no way i was
getting that job i had done zero
preparation for it um but also struck me
that that's a really broken way to
interview and to hire somebody that my
job performance my abilities to help
them get results is based on if y know
about these current events that are
happening um so that was probably the
most murmur when I walked out of there
knowing that like there's no way I'm
getting this job not even close I moved
on um in terms of interviews I've given
I haven't done that many and I don't
know if there's anything super memorable
um again I try to avoid interviews yeah
yes you're saying my process I think we
had said that knowledge is really
interesting and I do agree there's a
huge divide between what you're asked
often times versus what you do and it's
like you know why ask this when what I
mean in doing is going to be entirely
different so what advice would you have
been for someone what are the most key
things for you first 90 days even 30
days in a new job to make sure that you
can have an impact if it's possible
within such a short period of time yeah
I think it's looking at doing not just
what you're hired to do but but more so
obviously you're hard to do a certain
role but the guys who move up the guys
who get the the credit the guys who get
the promotions you know the guys who get
those those bigger positions they seek
to understand what the business is all
about and take on more responsibilities
so you know in those first 90 days
you're proving yourself and I'd be
looking at how can I get more involved
in the company how can I get as close to
ideally the CEO is faucet but depending
on the size of the company that's not
always possible but but taking on more
like make your manager's job easier take
on more responsibility there's no
manager no boss is gonna say no don't do
less you know right so show initiative
right yes call show gumption show the
willingness and desire to do more than
just what you were hired to do because
those are the star employees who rise up
quickly I great no I completely can
cover that and I was excited to ask you
this question because if someone was to
ask you Evan in your view what's the
secret to success what would you say to
that question you've got to love what
you do that one's an easy one for me ah
yeah a lot of people I know the people
listening on your you know program there
you're looking for jobs and trying to
figure that out um a lot of people hate
what they do a lot of people wake up
every day and go to a nine-to-five job
and they're living for the weekends and
evenings and they started on a path that
they may have had some interest in or
they may have had some you know family
pressures to say hey you need to go and
be this accountant or lawyer or doctor
or some professional um and and you
found that yeah as you practice you get
better at that skill but you don't love
what you do and so you're you're in I
don't know you're for me that's hell
like doing stuff that you're not excited
about every day is not is not a way to
live for me and it's never been easier
to follow your passion and turn that
into a serious opportunity for yourself
you can make millions of dollars as a
professional gamer you can make millions
of dollars as a youtuber like these
things didn't exist before and a lot of
the advice that we're getting our from
people who a lot of the advice that you
get from your parents some guidance
counselors from people who are experts
are never actually live their dreams
never
took any major risk and they're living
in the world that is really out of touch
is what's possible right now and so are
those the people that you really want to
listen to and I'm a father so I I you
know my son is only five years old so
he's not talking about career advice yet
but I you know I worried that I'm not
going to be able to give him the right
advice and and you know I think people
should follow their dreams follow your
passion if it doesn't make sense you'll
figure out a way to make it work and
that success you look at the top people
in any field any field where there's a
corporation or business the people who
are at the top they love what they do
they live for it and you've got to find
that and not settle for something that's
just okay okay okay and could you on a
personal note could you tell me a little
bit about one of the common questions
that I get when it comes to people that
either thinking about a career change or
are going into the world of employment
or there's this struggle to Evan I'm not
really sure what it is that I want to do
that you know sometimes I get told arts
it's easy if you because you seem to
have a clearer pot how is it that you
found your path was there a process was
there a singular moment was it
serendipity how is it that you found
your passion because I'm often time
that's been a big problem for that I get
asked about yeah a great question and
ennis by trying and I was helping
somebody this morning with the same
problem it's by trying you don't you
don't find your passion by thinking
about it you find that by trying stuff
and so many people are afraid to try
even on the small scale they're afraid
to try and and they're just continuing
on with their unhappy existence so if
you're excited by the opportunity of
doing something go out and try it on a
small scale and and see if you fall in
love with it and it's like if you're
trying to find the perfect wife or
perfect husband yeah you can look at it
on paper as much as you want but you're
not going to know if that's the right
person for you until you try right until
you ask her out you till you ask for her
phone number you can find out a lot more
in that first date with her than the
months of thinking about and planning on
who that right perfect fit is for you
and often times you get surprised you
know I I do a lot in the salsa world
I'm a salsa dancer I'm a DJ I'm an owner
in a business I'll spend upwards of 25
hours a week doing salsa stuff and and
on paper looks it looks it would be like
a terrible opportunity for me I'm too
tall I don't speak Spanish I take big
steps I didn't have salsa growing up
there's all these things that on paper
look bad for me and if I went into it
thinking this has to be my next business
opportunity I would say no way it
doesn't make any sense but I just went
and I tried for fun and I fell in love
with it and I got better and I became a
professional dancer and was able to DJ
and teach and so you never know what
you're gonna fall in love with but you
gotta try and there's some things you'll
try you'll know instantly that's not for
me rock climbing I hate rock climbing I
can't stand it you know I love all the
rock climbers out there but for me the
thing in your crotch and like I'm afraid
of heights and like I can't do it and so
I know that I know I went once I know
I'm not going back I fell in love with
salsa and that became a business
opportunity for me and just something
very fulfilling for me as well and so if
you're not sure what you want to do
that's normal that's okay that's cool ah
try I landed on this helping
entrepreneurs because I I built the
business and i sold it i was invited to
go and speak at an event and only three
people ended up showing you this free
event and i was a little disappointed
but uh but i loved it like the three
people who came out and listen to me I
loved it I fell in love with it I said I
have to find a way to keep doing this
and I would never have known if I didn't
go and try so try things even if it's a
little you got a strict your comfort
zone see what you fall in love with and
then find ways to continue to expand it
I would love to be able to take that
well thank God it's recorded and
repeated leviton to my to my clients and
saying when they all smell said well
this is what Evan said I i concur
completely okay I know that we learn a
few minutes left so I'm gonna ask you
some tell me some some quicker questions
and tell me one thing that I as of yet
could not YouTube or Google about you
that both our audiences don't know about
to you ah that's interesting i share a
lot on my channel so um what's
interesting that people don't know about
me hmm I was a bad student when I
started I was a bad student growing up
and I used my sister's always did well
and I used to always have that annual
sit down with my parents where we looked
at my report card and and and they would
always tell me you are my mom's last
name is Chris truly so you are cuz truly
Carmichael and you could do better than
this and I was always positive but I
always felt bad that I was
underperforming and then in my last year
in high school I over achieved my my own
expectations for myself were beyond what
my parents expected of me and that was
interesting change where I was always
trying to live up to their expectations
and then a big change happen when I
started believing in myself more than
than anybody else and I had higher
demands on myself than anybody else and
I started to change my life so okay
there yeah something I haven't said
before one more question perfect ok this
is I'm quite curious to get your insight
into this and I was I was I was asked
this by someone who'd pursued
entrepreneurship and then decide was
reentering employment and this is what
he had said to me he said I have this
feeling that the idea of
entrepreneurship and following your
dream is kind of mis-sold popularly
because he said that it's equally as if
not harder than actually pursuing a
career and he says that he feels that
there's a little sense of an illusion
almost as what he spoke of because he
said that I tried really hard and I did
things I was passionate and it didn't
work out what would you say to someone
who kind of comes to you with this this
kind of position it is harder starting
the business is the hardest thing you're
ever going to do in your life if you
think it's easy you're in the wrong
business ah and you have to be a little
bit crazy honestly uh because it's so
hard that the only thing that keeps you
going is that deep passion for what
you're doing it doesn't work out at the
start it like it never works out at the
start you make so many mistakes you're
losing money you're not getting the
results as quickly
you want your self-worth is in the
toilet because you're having no success
uh and it's just a sense of what you're
doing is right and you're so passionate
about it that you have to keep going
that that me how that when I went to
speak to entrepreneurs in that group you
know I didn't know if I'd ever make
money doing okay I can only get three
people to come out to a free event how
am I going to make this a business
opportunity there's no way but I almost
didn't care like I knew it filled me up
so much that I had to find a way to keep
doing it and eventually I turned that
into a business but uh you're going to
make so many mistakes at the start and
if you think that doing a business is a
sec seem fun and cool it is but it's
also the hardest thing you're going to
do in your life so you got to be
prepared for the hard work I we're at
the time Deepak think that are the
questions maybe we'll do it again for
people who want to learn more about you
where can they go the CV guide com one
word the CV guide com you'll find Evans
answers up there shortly thank you so
much Evan for your time I said it
awesome thanks Deepak we'll talk soon
cheers right